i'm craig or huge dressed as Black Widow
today I am guys follow her on Instagram
and twitch I think one time she dressed
like Black Widow sort of sort of you got
the red hair you got the black clothes
its Black Widow enough have you seen the
independent hit film Avengers end game
remember I know it's kind of a sleeper
memories but watch your blooper again
lines an end game that are more
important than you realized
endgame is one of those films that has
so much in it that every once in a while
I watch a new video and I'm like oh did
not know about that let's learn a thing
or two with allusions to previous MCU
movies and references to comics I
haven't made their way to the big screen
Avengers end game reminds Marvel fans
are the people behind the camera are
just as enthusiastic as the ones filling
the seats here are some lines in
Avengers ends game that were more
important than you may have realized I
got my pen ready minute packed theater
than the moment Thor's hammer Mjolnir
flies into Captain America's hand
probably inspired one of the loudest and
the most enthusiastic responses from the
audience oh yeah who yells I knew it at
these spots cap threatening Panos with
the legendary weapon so what did Thor
mean by I knew it in an early scene
none of his mere mortal teammates will
prove worthy to wield the hammer until
Steve Rogers gives a shot that brief
nudge and the past comic book stories in
which cap is proven worthy of Mjolnir
left some fans theorizing that cap could
have lifted the hammer but chose not to
in order to spare his teammate any
humiliation
Ryden son was one of those fans when
Thor yells I knew it he betrays I
thought cap was faking way back in 2015
as well and how couldn't today perhaps
as worthy as they come speaking of Thor
and what he may or may not be worthy to
wield the Thunder God initially thinks
he's the only one capable of using the
new infinity gauntlets to bring back
everyone Connors first in Avengers
infinity war okay I'll use a Bowser and
eventually it's the Hulk who convinces
everyone he's the only guy for the job
as he does it's made clear he's thinking
about a conversation he had seven years
before with Tony Stark
why Avengers a stark and Bruce Banner
look for a way to track the tesseract
Downey brings up banners of the guy and
compares it to the arc reactor which at
the time was still the only thing
stopping shrapnel in Starks chest from
killing him however understand Starks
suggestion that the Hulk saved banners
life in a gamma-ray explosion but isn't
totally on board with the idea - nice
sentiment
saved it from what
I guess we'll find out in a vendor's
ends game ah oh he's the only one who
can wield the stones and up there radio
hi Nadia got my man and turned them into
the Hulk
his assignment is to retrieve the eye of
agamotto aka the time stone instead of
dr. strange the Hulk finds the ancient
one waiting for him at a sanctum
sanctorum banner and the ancient one
argue over whether or not it makes sense
for her to risk our own timeline by
handing over the stone it's when the
ancient one learns that strange gave the
time stone to fellows that she changes
her mind right on that quote strange is
meant to be the best of us actually
gives him the time stone meaning that
she realizes her future students
wouldn't surrender the stone unless
there was a good reason considering what
happens in 2016 dr. strange the ancient
ones reaction is interesting for years
from when she calls him the best of us
she'll have strange physically thrown
out of karma Tosh you could call this a
contradiction but it could also suggest
a lot more complexity to the early
source for a supreme and her decisions
that she expects strange to eventually
show up and wrestle with a decision or
whether or not to let him in or perhaps
a sensing moldos potential for turning
on his allies did she get strange out
just to see what more dates reaction
would be totally after Tony Stark
figures out time travel he settles down
on a couch with pepper and talks about
what he should do next he tells her that
part of him wants to scrap all his work
box it up and drop her to the bottom of
the lake this is the same pepper who
almost left Tony's employ in 2008 saya
man over his armored adventures and who
was ready to break up with him over his
constant tinkering in 2013's Iron Man 3
this is a new
level of Elaine she clearly developed a
sense of resigned acceptance since we
last saw her because her words seemed to
be what convinced Tony to take his near
innovation to the Avengers after
listening bright pepper tells him that
trying to stop him has been one of the
few great failures in her life it's
accurate as anyone who's seen of that
Iron Man entries can testify but there's
a bittersweet irony you don't see until
the end of the movies climactic battle
after Tony uses the Infinity stones to
buy part Palace and his forces he
collapses and struggles to hold on to
what little life he has left
capo builds herself to smile at a dying
husband and tells him quote you can rest
now and so he does finally and
tragically pepper gets Tony to kill when
Captain America proves himself worthy of
Mjolnir it isn't the only time in the
final battle that the yellow soldier has
fans clapping and cheering after the
heroes Sano's flourish and Avengers
infinity war finally appear along with
the forces of Wakanda karma Taj and
newest car cap takes his place at the
head of this army of resurrected friends
he leads the charge against Thanos dark
forces with the line comic book fans of
red so Wathan Avengers Assemble
you may not even realize it until that
moment that we've been waiting for over
10 years to hear cap say it he may have
led the team Jerome 12 to vengers but he
never said the line he even teased us
whether the clothes of Avengers age of
Ultron
[Music]
what captain endgame if you hadn't
realized it before it's suddenly
accursed
Oh nipple chills it's Emma Furman
playing Scott Lang's daughter Cassie an
Avengers end game not the young Gabby
Ryder courtesan who plays her that man
and that man and the wasp but that
doesn't stop Scott from recognizing her
when he returns from the quantum realm
at the end of their reunion scene Scott
says you're so big it seems fairly
obvious and it's something adults say to
kids all the time if they haven't seen
them for a bit you're so big and so well
grown but it is a double meaning
understood by fans of the comics in 2004
the comic book version of Scott Lang was
seemingly one of the fatal victims of
Marvel's Avengers disassembled defense
in the wake of his death his daughter
becomes the hero stature as part of
Young Avengers like a father she has
powers I can make a smaller stature dies
just after her father was brought back
to life in 2010's Avengers The
Children's Crusade thankfully Cassie B
joins the land of the living and is
reunited with her father and 2015 event
as well if you 16
because you know she the Marvel Comics
characters sure sure mandatory is the
first to get his hands on the new
Infinity Gauntlet he holds on to the
thing for a while fighting up a storm
about riders and surviving an attempt to
steal that by the 2014 version of nebula
but once the poached heroes return and
things get real Hawkeye calls for help
the first hero to respond this Black
Panther who calls out Clint give it to
me it's not a particularly memorable
line until you remember how these
characters met and the fact that they
only exchanged two lines of dialogue
before endgame in particular their
entire conversation was about Hawkeye's
for your name and how little it mattered
so it's kind of funny that's the name
Black Panther uses an end game in 2016
Stark a civil war during the airport
battle and shortly after ant-man shocks
the other heroes by turning giant
instead of tiny T'Challa advances on
Hawkeye the conversation that follows is
short and to the point
I don't care
apparently he started carrying just a
little bit more by the time ends game
rolled around forever as shield
operatives were actually Hydra agents
slowly for the elevators the brightest
is taking and the old soldier soon
realizes it's walked into a death trap
avengers endgame gives fans a scene
acting as both sequel and creep all as
it takes place moments after Loki's
capture in 2012 Avengers shield agents
are transporting Loki's staff Dillon the
Captain America from the future
intercepts them in the elevator he's
able to convince them to hand over the
scepter when he whispers hail Hydra the
line references the Marvel comic
storyline that introduced a version of
Captain America who was secretly serving
Hydra this overrides Hydra cap is
eventually defeated at the end of the
2017 line wide event secret Empire ends
game also echoes that series when
shortly after getting the scepter
Captain America 2019 is forced to fight
his double from 2012 just as the real
Steve Rogers defeated his Hydra
counterpart in secret Empire there are a
lot of sad moments in Avengers and games
resolution but one of the funniest
involves floor and the guardians of the
galaxy boarding the Benatar with a heavy
sack Thor treats the spacefaring pre
result friends and slaps star-lord on
the back and saves as guardians of the
galaxy base weapons to us guardians of
the galaxy is more than City wordplay in
2018 Marvel for me at the comic as
guardians of the galaxy
featuring Australian characters on a
state's quest the most recognizable
characters - MCU fans would be scourge
the executioner
played by Karl Urban in thor ragnarok
and a younger version of Loki who begins
a series hidden in a destroyer zama is
also Valkyrie
Grogg the front of thunder when the full
like a hero Thunder strike considering
what are we getting the progress what
are we gonna get that
question two is referencing moon
depending on exactly when the scene was
filmed his store referencing the comic
in that scene or was he has guardians of
the galaxy comic inspired by that line
from the script surely after reading his
support group he visits Black Widow at
the Avengers compound he talked with his
old friend about moving on from the
purge telling her
[Music]
the Japs talking about accepting the
losses here in natural sucks rather than
trying to find a way to our person but
there's a bittersweet foreshadowing to
the line as the movie continues by the
time the credits roll the Captain
America and Black Widow are two
characters who have definitely moved on
black widow sacrifices herself to get
the soulstone come for Mia while Steve
Rogers uses his quest to return the
Infinity stones to be capped to the life
he lost when he plunged into the ice in
Captain America the First Avenger if you
weren't already crying that reveal most
likely triggered a few happy tears now I
really want that Asgardian to the
gallery Rocket Raccoon in a frog thunder
interacting with one another like God I
mean they're saying lines and endgame
that are more important than you realize
some of them are a little bit more
obvious like Thor saying I knew it like
yeah of course it's referencing that
moment and these guardians of the galaxy
line yeah didn't know there was a comic
strip may I eventually heard about it
but when I heard the line I was like oh
that's funny it's cover it's clever
funny writers didn't even know there was
an authority there's a lot of talk about
Thor potentially being guardians three I
don't want them being in guardians day
yeah I'm not I don't like that idea if
that would distract cuz they're supposed
to be the closing film for the guardians
of the galaxy the final film and like
the trilogy and I think it's too much
attention but to be drawn to Thor being
in it I forget did Thor is he still fat
and ugly
um well that depends on your subjective
taste of a man if he fat her and ugly
her then he was and past some think he
was more attractive and maybe uglier
what he was not overweight
yeah by the end of the film he's still
the way he is when he let himself go
yeah well there's a deleted post-credit
scene where he is doing a juice cleanse
I mean I mean it gets back into shape I
would love to hey you're honest you like
honesty around here but I would never
say that same kind of thing about a
woman thank you all ideas one woman's
permission that's not true don't listen
to me that whole thing with Holt
saying I was made for this before he
dons the gauntlet and I'm I never
thought it because she did pass that but
the line stood out to me cuz I was like
what does he mean by I'm made for this
like alright the Hulk oh this may be
thought your destiny was but I didn't
read into it at all that there was some
potential foreshadowing from an earlier
movie and that being the first Avengers
movie which i think is pretty freakin
cool if you asked me I'm going so
impressive people who can make those
connections good night it's hard to read
somebody you have to like watch all of
them cause it's like my obsession with
the show friends that's where I can do
the histories and all that the Avengers
Assemble line it clearly you don't watch
run the Avengers Assemble does that
throw in the show friends this is a read
it whatever like everything maybe their
friends manner whatever Juliet this is
your last video the Avengers Assemble
line it didn't register my brain until
he said it I'm like wait that was the
first time we've ever heard and say
Avengers Assemble and you gotta think
about that for me yes yeah I remember
the joke at the end of age of Ultron
hymns and Avengers and is about to say
it but you gotta imagine from an actor's
standpoint the pressure to make sure you
nail yeah yeah who did it like but he
says that
here that one phrase yeah and like the
way they capture with the music the
camera panning on him catching the
hammer and then he says assemblies guys
teeth grinding yeah Cassy Lang and man's
daughter I don't know I don't know if
I'd give that to them that you're so big
line yeah yeah and especially in this
situation I think they're giving the
writers too much credit see the thing is
now they can easily say but that's what
they intend right yeah like yes I am
smarter than of course we knew it's be
smart when you interviewed us later it's
like anytime you used to work big or
small around them mr. egghead no it's
just the line yeah that is fascinating
about Clint they only did exchanged like
two lines of dialogue before man two
challahs memory people don't know is
that black panther secretly has posted
notes whatever he's read had a what
friends and influence people and he
wants to make sure he's he's got his
communication skills down he knows keys
to remember the names
he's royalty it's important you know he
didn't have his assistant around so he's
got to apply the tricks himself we got a
good back and forth here hail Hydra line
okay you know as much as I don't think
the kasi line on the big is implied
there because I thought that hail Hydra
line was just in reference to he knows
they're part of Hydra yeah but I could
see the writers say like yeah we are
nodding to the Captain America comics of
that point I hope when they bring back
Captain America they do that just to
ruin ruin his character just piss off
Chris Evans comes out of retiring the
character and this is what he does and
they kill him subscribe if you haven't
done so already which line an end game
of these sadati the most follow Juliet
on youdo not you too
on Instagram and twitch as soon as you
can
links in the description box and pink
comment subscribe click notification
bell for us and last but not least it's
time for Lanai jones Lenny
Gregg poem time get ready good luck
they're ready to receive in the fields
hey hey hey it's always a good day when
I get a message from Lynnae goes by
canary arrow let's drink together like
Captain Jack Sparrow I'll worship at
your feet
call you a pharaoh and give you a gift
maybe a Camaro California to Texas
patrons are Nexis up your pledge and
I'll buy you a Lexus got us out of our
nestling by sharing your love of
wrestling got a tea from a player in WWE
oh I should have worn that shirt today
so should I buy I'll hook you up expect
the callin from Seth Rollins you'll be
crying when you hug Daniel Bryan Miss
Jones I hope this poem doesn't make you
groan and I hope one day I will break
out of this forbidden friendzone